17 millones de dólares 1 millón por
persona es el precio que los
secuestradores haitianos piden a la
organización religiosa basada en ohio
cristiana ministros por la liberación de
sus 17 misioneros capturados el sábado
en los suburbios de puerto príncipe
entre los rehenes 5 niños y 12 adultos
son 16 estadounidenses y un canadiense-
la demanda fue hecha al director en
haití de cristian administre pidieron un
millón de dólares por persona muchas
veces esas pandillas saben que sus
demandas no pueden ser satisfechas y
consideran una contraoferta de las
familias por lo que las negociaciones
pueden tomar un par de días o algunas
veces un par de semanas los 17
misioneros estaban en haití para visitar
un orfanato cuando fueron capturados en
croix de bouquets por lo que se atribuye
al secuestro a la banda 400 magos que
controla la zona y se financia en parte
gracias a los rescates masivos en medio
de la inestable situación política el
poder de las bandas de crimen organizado
ha aumentado en el último año en haití
como respuesta este lunes el país se
declaró en huelga contra la inseguridad
en todos los países la seguridad es el
primer bien común significa que cuando
estás en un país sin seguridad una banda
te fuerza a desplazarte te secuestra
vieron a tus hijos cuando no puedes
comer eso también es inseguridad leo
tuvo para comunicarse de suscribirte el
youtube
vivimos en la inseguridad en todos los
ámbitos inseguridad financiera económica
alimentaria nos ponen en una posición de
normalización de la inseguridad no
podemos continuar en una situación así
el país más pobre de américa está sumido
en una crisis sanitaria social y
política un estado de convulsión
agravado por el magnicidio de job en el
mois el 7 de julio y por el terremoto
del 14 de agosto en la zona de los cayos
mientras el primer ministro ariel ndri
prometió una reforma de la constitución
y elecciones presidenciales en 2022